hi everyone
i'm maya jama and in honor of soccer aid
we're doing england
versus the world let's go
oh of course i knew there's gonna be
something disgusting on here
jellied eels oh my goodness it looks
like little brains
england's the jelly deals bradley's as
well
who's bradley and then this is smoke
sprout and oil okay
both sound absolutely disgusting
oh no i'm scared it's gonna like juice
me when it opens
oh oh no
look at look at it that is like cat food
oh they say never smell it never smell
[Music]
oh
hmm there you go no
it's not that bad it's really fishy the
texture is better than i thought i can't
stop thinking of fat food
oh and people choose to eat that
sorry okay let's go to the next
[Music]
so that's like mackerel which is really
like just the texture is not really nice
but it is mackerel
so the winner of this one is gonna be
poland
okay all right english one i'll try
first
no that's not very nice at all now it
tastes like old
do you know what i mean like just really
old i'm sorry if you love this drink
then we've got a guinness i'm not gonna
say anything bad about guinnesses
because people love
a goodness
you're supposed to do that
it's actually quite nice the actual swig
of it's all right decent
i'm 100 gonna go for the guinness it
doesn't have an old taste to it
not that bad well i think seven five
percent
irish who is that
love the irish oh
that's all right so we've got
toxic waste hazardously sour candy i
know that's the one that makes your eyes
water
and love hearts which are just you know
little love hearts
on the tongue
[Music]
oh my god i hate that that's too bad
no i'm past it now once you get past the
harshness
oh all right okay the love hearts it
makes you have a lot of saliva in your
mouth afterwards
oh it says nothing it's actually
is that bad luck it's a crying sad face
in a love heart i thought you know i was
supposed to have nice messages
share the love and i get a crying sad
face that's good yeah
these are nice cute um not sure but
what is it like dusty sweets it's like
it feels like a
dusty sweet but nice my winner
is probably actually gonna be the toxic
waste it set me off a little bit
but the aftertaste was really nice and
watermelon
so i think if you can get past that
toxic waste twins
[Music]
all right el clasico
mr porky original scratching
seaweed crisps it's looking like crispy
seaweed
okay i'm just gonna go with the trusted
favorite but little story i used to get
these on my way to school and
then one day there was a hair in like
hairy back or something i don't know
what part of the pig it came from but
the hair was stuck in my turf and it put
me off
i mean yeah i mean the whole idea of
them was a bit left isn't it
scratch of a pig um okay
yeah all right
i mean to a lot of people it's probably
a habit to me it's all right it's not
bad
[Applause]
oh no i'm so weak oh no no look
and i still can't bloody okay
tough entry right
so these look quite interesting but
again i have actually tried quite a lot
of crispy seaweed
crispy things and they like them
lovely very very nice with a little bit
of spice to it as well
so i'm gonna go with these because that
one strand of hair
ruined everything well i guess that's it
the rest of the world completely smashed
the life out of england now
i'm sorry with fish early no those are
disgusting
yeah and it is
[Music]
no i'll put those eyes for a second it's
a black bean